François mesdames mesdemoiselles
messieurs le 11 octobre 1952 les joueurs
du Canadien de Montréal vont apparaître
pour la première fois à la télévision
jamais il me semble nous commanditaires
n'auraient pu choisir meilleur parti
pour nos débuts à la télévision comme
l'explique l'historien du hockey car la
vigne on ne diffusait à l'époque la
troisième période et ça y est la
troisième période est en marche on se
regroupait chez celui qui avait la télé
et on écoutait le match de hockey qui
ont le sait comment se traiteur donc en
troisième période à l'époque on avait
cette peur que la télévision Vienne
nuire à la vente de billets
même chose pour canadienne 9 Richard la
description de René le cavalier va
donner le ton au match de hockey en
inventant un nouveau vocabulaire en
français qui fera école mais c'est
Richard et Sinclair se font de mauvaises
René petit et pierroudaient ses matchs
sur une petite télévision en noir et
blanc sans se douter qu'un jour il
marcherait sur les traces du célèbre
animateur mes souvenirs vont souvent
dans le sens de René le cavalier qui
nous accueille bonsoir madame messieurs
et bien ces 4 à 0 pour le Canadien c'est
pas vrai on a manqué quatre buts
rebonsoir tout le monde et bien pendant
que le Canadien se heurte une équipe
tenace cet homme-là
inventé vraiment leur inventer un
lexique
canadien français ce qu'on dit à
l'époque
un tour de force
[Applaudissements]
gardien prenez en note des expressions
et lorsqu'elles étaient utilisées ils
bippait ses expressions dans son carnet
pour éviter de les répéter trop souvent
derrière ces buts à cache-cache les
premières prises de vue des matchs de la
soirée du hockey étaient faites avec
trois caméras durant 20 ans Jacques
primo en a été le réalisateur il a vu la
télévision évolué et c'est lui qui
captera des images qui resteront dans
les annales de l'histoire du hockey
[Musique]
dans le gardien puis tout ça aujourd'hui
chaque Cameron fonctionne la caméra
portative derrière les buts permet de
mieux capter tous les aspects du jeu en
70 ans d'histoire lequel la télévision a
bien évolué certains pourront se vanter
d'avoir assisté à la naissance d'une
tradition d'autres feront en sorte de la
perpétuer ici Robert Crozier
Radio-Canada Montréal